what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to icarly
freestyle by ddg
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell as you guys know i'm trying to hit
20 000 subscribers and
each and every one of you helps me get
to that goal okay
trying to be uh
just be too raw boy
[Music]
oh my gosh you see
this intro like this theme song was
literally fire
oh my gosh
[Music]
i don't like nice girls i want a mean
[ __ ] still throw it back and she
cooking she clean [ __ ] hit him and i
put her straight
okay so he's saying that like he does
not want a girl that's nice to him
he wants someone that's like
you know just gonna be on the meaner
side um and i'll
hook up with him whenever he wants on
the cool hoes little whip
42 in my cup [ __ ] i love to sip i just
ate a stream out of my pocket [ __ ] i
love to trip
don't do ga i'm popping [ __ ] i love it
rose gold prezzy
that's like 50k i can make a million
dollars on a busy day
say she wanna kick it like his mma don't
waste my time i ain't gonna play [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the game okay so he's letting
girls know that like do not waste his
time like
he's here for one thing and don't waste
his time he's also flexing like he's
letting
like his friends and family know that
he's got money
he can make a million in a day if you
wanted to [ __ ] with you lames [ __ ]
you can get your digits up
and he's letting you know if you don't
got money he's not gonna mess with you
you are
you're then like what they call a lame
and that just basically means that like
you're not cool and he's cool my lane
police got me [ __ ] imma rip the
ticket up
yeah i was making plays off a telegraph
made it in when i was 20 [ __ ] do the
math oh
he got hands that's right cause we gonna
shoot his ass brody got away because he
slid with a kobe master
i [ __ ] icarly if i had a chance made a
quarter million dollars on my only fans
i fly white [ __ ] to bodies just to get
a 10.
[ __ ] on the beach i got my toes
curled in the sand okay so
now he's just listing like different
sexual stuff that he either wants to do
or like has done so he's saying like the
girl from miranda cosgrove he'd hook up
with her
and she's really pretty i understand
that
um wait oh my god
not like okay but and then he's also
saying
like he's gonna fly like girls
out to different locations so he can
like
hook up with them and spend time with
them [ __ ] with me fly her out while this
[ __ ] keep on bugging me
[ __ ] insect i take a [ __ ] [ __ ] action
where's [ __ ] at walking in the party i
ain't acting with no lipstick
face car good [ __ ] know their name
[ __ ] say beefing with me i don't know
the lame whole lot of [ __ ] hating on
me but they fans of me
i know my ex see this new [ __ ] on the
ground with me
i actually think this is really catchy
with the theme song
in the background like i actually really
like the beat of this song
okay i think that rap music is growing
on me lately because
i've been given a lot of fours and fives
lately and i'm gonna give this song
a five out of five i really like the
beat i thought that the music video was
super well produced
and like very entertaining to watch
throughout the whole
thing um
yeah so actually i give it a 5 out of 5.
so let me know what you guys would rank
this song in the comments on a scale one
two five
um do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time